JUDITH D. SINGER: Thank
you all for coming out
to today's new
Faculty Institute.
I'm just going to make
a few opening remarks
and then introduce provost
Alan Garber, who will also
make some opening remarks.
And then I'll come back on.
One request I have is don't
sit next to somebody you know.
The whole purpose of this is
to meet people you don't know.
And we are trying to encourage
those kinds of opportunities.
And there will be a
break, and there will also
be a reception afterwards
where there will
be more opportunity for that.
Just want to say a few words
of introduction about why we do
this new Faculty Institute.
I am the Senior Vice Provost
for Faculty Development
and Diversity.
I started in this role in 2008.
And one of the
commitments that I
had when I started was to try
to make faculty at Harvard
feel not just part of their
department or their school,
but part of Harvard University.
Harvard is a fabulous place
with lots of interesting people
and lots of rich opportunities.
But historically, the university
had too few opportunities
to do these kinds of things.
In fact, I was just talking
with one of our panelists
about this.
And when I was hired in
1984-- so it's 30 years ago--
I was given keys
to an office and I
was told to go to
an HR orientation
to learn about my
health benefits,
and then I started teaching.
So Harvard in those
days did nothing.
Harvard in those days did
not have a tenure track.
It did not have a commitment
to its assistant and associate
professors.
The Harvard of today is really
quite different in terms
of what we are trying to
accomplish as a university,
and why you were all selected
by your colleagues who
put in an enormous
amount of work
to identify you
as people to come
into our vibrant community.
What you'll learn, if
you haven't already,
is that Harvard's a great
place to be a faculty
member for a variety of
reasons, some obvious,
some not so obvious.
The obvious ones are
fabulous colleagues.
I mean, when you
came and interviewed,
when you had
conversations, you really
got a sense, hopefully,
of the excitement.
There is a little bit of
Harvard exceptionalism
that we sometimes take too
much advantage of and sometimes
can make light of.
But one of the things today is
to meet colleagues who are not
in your immediate sphere.
So either people
from other parts
of the university who do
work similar to you or people
in your part of the
university who do
work dissimilar from you.
And I hope you take
the chance to do that.
How many of you are
teaching right now?
Yeah.
So once you start
teaching, you just
get a sense of how
vibrant the students are,
how exciting they are,
how challenging they are,
how they make you think.
They make you think
you don't know
things you thought you know.
They make you go home
and work on things
that you didn't know you were
going to work on because they
asked you a question
you actually
don't know the answer
to and you're terrified.
You'll also have
fabulous opportunities.
This is part of the
Harvard exceptionalism.
Being here opens doors.
Being at Harvard, people like
to have people on panels.
People like to solicit people.
And it's also just a great place
to do research and scholarship
and engage, whether it's
with our library collections,
with our art collections, with
our scientific facilities.
Whatever it is that
you're interested in,
Harvard has a wealth
of resources in this.
So I'm going to stop right
now because Alan's time is
rather tight, and introduce
Alan Garber who is our provost.
He is now no longer a newbie.
He has been here--
this is your--
ALAN M. GARBER: Fifth year.
JUDITH D. SINGER:
--fifth year, wow.
OK.
It's Alan's fifth year.
Alan bleeds crimson.
He went here as
an undergraduate,
did some training here.
He is an MD/PhD,
PhD in economics,
and brings his skills both as an
MD and able to work with people
and as a PhD in
economics in terms
of analyzing higher education
and the finances of higher
education and how things run.
And we've invited Alan here
to just make a few welcoming
remarks, and also
if we have some time
to take some questions
from folks in the audience.
So let me introduce Alan Garber.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN M. GARBER: Thank you, Judy.
First of all, I just
want to add my welcome.
We're delighted that
you're all here.
I'm not talking about for
this afternoon's event,
although we are
happy about that,
but that you're here at Harvard.
And for us, success
means that your career
grows beyond your wildest dreams
as a result of your coming
to Harvard to be faculty.
Whether you are a junior faculty
member or a newly recruited
tenured professor,
Harvard is a place
where we want you to achieve
your professional aspirations.
I don't have a lot
of advice for you.
Sometimes I'm asked for advice.
And I have four
children, I should add,
and I know how rare it is
to be able to give somebody
advice where they ask for it and
they'll actually listen to you.
As provost, people
will always at least
go through the motions
of sounding grateful.
But I have some
advice that I think
is really worth
following, and this is
the advice I want to give you.
When you think about
what Harvard offers,
Judy touched on a lot of
what makes Harvard great.
We have the largest
university endowment.
Although if you look at a per
student or per faculty basis,
we do not.
We have the most distinguished
faculty in the world,
arguably, although we do
have plenty of competition.
Tomorrow's New
York Times is going
to have a story that
rankles a little bit having
to do with economics.
But we certainly do have
a distinguished faculty.
We have the world's
largest library.
Largest research
library, I should say.
And it's the fourth
largest library
in the world by many measures.
We have our art museum.
We have many museums on campus.
Our art museum is
by some measures
the sixth largest art
museum in the country.
Not among academic institutions,
among all art museums.
And the list goes on and on.
We have many
treasures that we own.
We have many things
that make Harvard
look like a spectacular place.
But what I think is the
genuine distinction of Harvard
and why it is so terrific
to be a faculty member here
or a student here is that
our excellence extends
across so many different areas.
So many areas of academic,
of intellectual pursuit.
Very few universities are
even competitive with us
in this regard.
So many of you have
come here to be
in the top ranked department
in your field, or at least one
of the top ranked departments.
And you undoubtedly
will feel that it's
a great environment for
you to advance your career,
to conduct your research, to
teach with tremendous students,
and so on.
What I want to urge you to do is
to look beyond your department,
even to look beyond your school.
And now I'm going
to be shameless
about this for a moment.
But one of the things that's
challenging about Harvard
is it's difficult to get
to know people who are not
in your immediate environment.
And we try to create
opportunities for you
to meet other people.
This afternoon is one of them,
but we need to have many more
and we do have many more.
And I want to urge you to
take advantage of them,
of those opportunities.
If it's 4:30 in the
afternoon on a Wednesday,
you may have a stack of
student papers to grade,
referee reports to write,
recommendation letters
to write, a whole
series of things
that you have to do every day.
And I know all of you
are very busy already.
And you have many, many
things weighing on you.
The easiest thing to do is to
always plow through the work
that you have ahead
of you and ignore
some of the invitations,
some of the seminars,
some of the
performances that you
get invited to in the normal
course of a week at Harvard.
I want to urge you to think
about sometimes dropping
that work that you
need to do for a while
to take advantage of an event.
Judy's office sponsors many
events to get faculty together.
Sometimes these are
special performances
at the ART, the American
Repertory Theater,
arguably the greatest
regional theater in America,
which we also own.
But there are many, many
activities that she sponsors
and you will have other
activities of that kind.
And what I want
to urge you to do
is get to know people
in other areas.
Go to a seminar
occasionally that's
outside your immediate
department or area,
but maybe that has some
loose relation to something
you're interested in.
Get out there.
Get to know people who
aren't in your field.
Sometimes the way to
get to know other people
is through students that you may
share in common, particularly
at the graduate level.
But also undergraduates
can be a bridge.
Sometimes you will be invited by
your students to attend events
at the houses or in Annenberg.
If they're freshmen,
they have faculty nights.
Accept those invitations.
Not only get to know students,
get to know other faculty.
There are many,
many opportunities,
and the biggest barrier is
the demands on your time.
And those demands, as you
know, are to a great extent
internally imposed.
You'd certainly have
obligations to others
who make demands on
your time, but you
will have to make a decision
about what the priorities are.
It's not sacrificing your
career to take advantage
of some of these
riches and people
that Harvard has to offer.
You will not have a fully
successful Harvard experience
if your entire academic life is
lived within your department.
So please, please take
advantage of the breadth
of what Harvard has to offer.
You will sometimes even
find very direct payoffs
in terms of your work from
having interacted with people
outside your immediate area.
The unexpected
collaboration or sometimes
you may read something
you wouldn't otherwise
read when you get to know
other people in the Harvard
environment outside your area.
So make the most
of this experience.
I wish you every success.
And Judy's office and
the provost's office
stand ready to help you
in every way we can.
Have a great experience.
Let me just ask if
people have questions
or want to make any comments.
And let me add one other thing.
Don't let the
river be a barrier.
Many of you are
here from the School
of Public Health, the med
school, the business school.
The river, it's a
very narrow river,
and the traffic can
be bad at rush hour
but it's pretty quick to get
in between during other times
of day.
And I would hate to
think of Longwood
as a different universe
or that Allston
is a different universe.
A lot of what we're going to be
doing in the next several years
is helping people understand
that Allston and Cambridge are
all one campus.
OK, thank you very much.
Good luck.
[APPLAUSE]
JUDITH D. SINGER:
Thank you, Alan.
I'm going to make a few
remarks about the university
before we go around the
room and say who we are
and what department we're in
so that people can get a chance
to know each other.
The first thing I'm
going to talk about
is-- I'm a statistician, so
I'll give some statistics.
As Alan was implying,
Harvard is a huge place.
And not counting
the hospitals, which
have about 10,000 faculty, we
have 1,500 ladder faculty who
are spread across our campuses.
They are increasingly
diverse, which
is something we are
very much committed to.
About 70% of the
faculty are tenured.
About 30% are tenure track.
29% are women.
That's an all time
high for Harvard.
It's really remarkable,
the progress
that we've been making.
And in the earlier ranks,
the fraction of women
is up to 38% which is
also an all time high.
So we're really making progress
in diversifying our faculty.
This year, 22% of our faculty
are members of minority groups.
That's an all time high.
And once again, in the assistant
and associate professor ranks,
we're at about 30% minority.
Your entering class
is also diverse.
39% female, 30% minority.
There are some places at
the Harvard faculty club
where all you see are
pictures of dead white men.
That's what Harvard was.
So when you look
around the room and you
see very different
faces, it's a sense
that this is a new Harvard.
And that's an institution
that very much I
want to be a part of and I
hope you want to be a part of.
The other part of
Harvard that's changing
is to some extent it's the way
we're organized and structured,
but it's also about
the opportunities
that Alan was talking about.
You may hear people talk about
every tub on its own bottom,
or the tub system.
This is a system where the
budgets are decentralized.
Each dean controls
his or her budget.
And part of that tub
system contributed
to a lot of city-states that
were somewhat balkanized.
And part of the mission of the
provost's office in general,
but also President Faust
since she took office in 2007,
is the phrase we use
is "One Harvard."
We actually want this to be
a university where people
feel part of the university.
They can move across
the university.
And that's what Alan was
trying to get at when he
was urging you to meet people.
The other thing
we've discovered is
that newer people are much more
interested in meeting people
than people who've been
here for 30 or 40 years.
So part of today is
focused on people
who are new to the university
and giving them an opportunity
to get to know each other.
If you haven't signed
up for our geomap,
you should have gotten
something in your packet.
I just met somebody who's
living down the street from me.
So it's a good
opportunity to get
to know faculty who
live in your community.
Find people you
might carpool with
or have a barbecue with,
who might live near you
or have kids the same
age as your kids,
and to feel part of Harvard.
Let me say a word
about today's program,
and then I'm going to have
us go around the room.
The idea here is we're going
to have two faculty panels,
and I'm pleased to see the first
panel actually has arrived.
I was beginning to have
that fear you have,
where are my speakers?
Thank you for coming.
And the first panel
is going to be
from people who were
relatively recently promoted
from assistant to
associate professors
to tell those of you who
are assistant professors
that it actually can happen
and does happen at Harvard.
And then our second
panel is going
to be of some tenured
faculty who have been here
for varying numbers of
years who will give you
a perspective on the
university that they
have from their perch.
Some of the questions we've
asked people to talk about
are what are the
critical factors
essential to your
development and feeling
part of the university.
What kinds of resources have you
found particularly effective?
Where do you go when
you have a question?
How do you find out how to
maneuver around this very
large and vast campus?
And how do you
develop relationships
and collaborations with faculty?
And how do you
balance those demands
of hunkering down and you've
got a paper you need to get out
and taking advantage
of those opportunities.
And so different people have
different perspectives on this.
And so what we're hoping
is by hearing these six
different voices who come
from different schools,
different disciplines, and are
at different career stages,
you'll get some food for thought
that hopefully will stimulate
your own thinking and
also conversations
that can take place at the
breaks and at receptions.
Both of the panels are going to
be introduced by my colleague.
Elizabeth Ancarana, who's the
Assistant Provost for Faculty
Development and Diversity.
And I would say that if
you don't have a place
to go to ask a
question, Elizabeth, me,
we are open to all
kinds of questions.
And we can direct you
to the right place
if we're not the right place.
So to start breaking
down some barriers,
let's go around
the room and have
everybody introduce themselves.
For time reasons,
let's keep it short.
So basically your
name, your school,
and your department or field.
And one sentence
about your research.
Hit it.
NATASHA SUMNER:
I'm Natasha Sumner.
I'm in Celtic Languages
and Literatures.
And I work on a heroic corpus
in Irish and Scottish Gaelic.
JUDITH D. SINGER: Perfect.
SCOTT CARTER: Scott Carter.
I'm a computational biologist
at the Harvard School for Public
Health in the Dana-Farber.
I'm working on human cancer,
genetics, and evolution.
MATTHEW HERSCH: Matthew Hersch,
faculty of Arts and Sciences,
History of Science.
I work on the history
of aerospace technology.
ISAAC CHIU: Hi.
My name's Isaac Chiu.
I'm in the Department
of Microbiology
and Amino Biology at
Harvard Medical School.
And I work on the interaction
between the nervous system
and immune system and
inflammation and pain.
MAOFA LIAO: Hi.
My name is Maofa Liao.
I'm in Cell Biology Department
at Harvard Medical School.
We mainly use electromicroscopy
to study protein structure
and function.
GARETH DOHERTY: My
name's Gareth Doherty.
I'm in the Department of
Landscape Architecture
at the Graduate
School of Design.
And I work on the
intersections between design
and anthropology.
CHRISTOPHER STANTON:
I'm Christopher Stanton
at the Business School, and I'm
an applied microeconometrician.
STEPHANE VERGUET:
Hi, Stephane Verguet,
Harvard Chan School
of Public Health
and Global Health Population.
And I work in priority
setting in global health,
and particularly equity
and poverty issues.
NIR EYAL: I'm Nir Eyal.
I know this guy, sorry, because
we're in the same department.
Global Health and Population
in the Public Health School.
And I'm an ethicist.
I do ethics at the
level of populations.
TAMARRA JAMES-TODD: Hello.
I'm Tamarra James-Todd.
I'm also at Harvard Chan
School of Public Health,
but I do not know
the two gentlemen
that I'm sitting next to.
I'm in the Department
of Environmental Health
and Epidemiology, and I look at
environmental and reproductive
predictors of women's
health outcomes.
TIM REBBECK: Hi,
I'm Tim Rebbeck.
At the Chan School of Public
Health and the Dana-Farber,
and I'm a cancer
molecular epidemiologist.
BETHANY HEDT-GAUTHIER: My
name is Bethany Hedt-Gauthier.
I'm a bio-statistician at
Harvard Medical School,
and I do research
on health system
strengthening and research
capacity building,
primarily in Rwanda.
DAVID STERN: My
name is David Stern
I'm in the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences in the departments
of Near Eastern Languages and
Civilizations and Comparative
Literature.
And I work in classical medieval
Jewish literature and culture,
and the history of the book.
BRANDON TERRY: Hi.
My name is Brandon Terry.
I'm also in the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences.
I'm in the Department of
African and African-American
Studies and Social Studies.
I'm a political theorist working
on African-American politics
and political thought.
JOE ALLEN: Hello.
Joe Allen, Harvard Chan
School of Public Health,
Department of
Environmental Health.
I study buildings
and their impact
on health, trying
to figure out how
to optimize indoor environments
for improved health.
MELANI CAMMETT: Hi.
I'm Melani Cammett.
I'm in Arts and Sciences in
the Department of Government,
and I work on the politics
of economic development
in the Middle East and
have a lot of projects
actually on the politics
of access to health care,
so sort of wannabe public
health person as well.
YUHUA WANG: I'm Yuhua Wang,
also in the Arts and Sciences
in the department of Government.
I'm a political scientist
doing work on Chinese politics.
STEPHEN GRAY: Hi,
I'm Stephen Gray.
Graduate School of Design.
I'm an urban designer in the
Department of Urban Planning
and Design, and I focus
on the intersection
among design democracy and
development in the city.
DANIELLE LEE: Hi,
I'm Danielle Lee.
I'm an economist at
the Business School,
and I study the
economics of science.
CHARLIE CONROY:
I'm Charlie Conroy.
I'm in the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences in the Astronomy
department, and I study
the formation and evolution
of galaxies.
SOROUSH SAGHAFIAN:
Soroush Saghafian
from Harvard Kennedy
School, and my area
is in operations research
and operations management.
I use them for studying
basically health care systems.
LUKE MIRATRIX: Hello.
I'm Luke Miratrix.
I'm in the School of Education.
And I work on
statistical methodology
for determining causality
and observational data,
and also do data mining
for text analysis.
STRATOS IDREOS: Hi,
I'm Stratos Idreos.
I'm a computer scientist in
the School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences.
And I work on data systems.
That's how you store,
access, and analyze
large amounts of data.
MADHU SUDAN: Hi.
I'm Madhu Sudan.
Sorry, I'm also a
computer scientist
from the School of Engineering,
so I'm sitting next to Stratos,
but I didn't really
know him till today.
I work in the mathematical
theories of computers
and communicating devices.
JEREMY FRIEDMAN: Hi.
I'm Jeremy Friedman.
I'm at the Business School
too, and I'm a historian
of communism and revolution.
GARY ADAMKIEWICZ: Hi,
I'm Gary Adamkiewicz.
I'm in the Department of
Environmental Health at the TH
Chan School of Public Health.
And I mostly work on
issues that connect housing
to health with a
focus on low income
communities and environmental
health disparities.
ANDREW HOLDER:
I'm Andrew Holder.
I'm in the Department
of Architecture
at the Graduate
School of Design.
And I'm working on
the resuscitation
of the Rococo and contemporary
building practice.
NICK MENZIES: Hi, my
name's Nick Menzies.
I'm one of many people, it
seems, from the Chan School
of Public Health.
I'm in the Department of
Global Health and Population.
And in my work, I
look at, I guess,
predicting the long term
outcomes of infectious disease
control policies.
ANKUR PANDYA: I'm Ankur Pandya.
I'm also from the Chan School in
the Department of Health Policy
and Management.
When not introducing
myself to economists,
I call myself a
health economist.
[LAUGHTER]
SHEILA ISANAKA:
I'm Sheila Isanaka.
I am at the School
of Public Health
in the departments of
Nutrition and Global
Health and Population.
I do clinical and
community-based research
looking at methods
to treat and prevent
child malnutrition and
infectious disease.
JUSTINE LANDAU: Hello.
I'm Justine Landau.
I'm at the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences
and the Department of
Near Eastern Languages
and Civilizations.
I teach classical
Persian literature,
and I study mostly
theories, classical theories
of literature, and poetics.
SEAN EDDY: I'm Sean Eddy.
I'm in the Department of
Molecular and Cellular Biology
and also in Applied Mathematics.
I'm a computational
biologist, and I
develop computational
tools for analyzing
the evolution of biological
sequences over very long time
scales.
SI NAE PARK: My
name is Si Nae Park.
I'm in the department
of East Asian Languages
and Civilizations.
I look at pre-modern
Korean literature
through the scope of
cosmopolitan and vernacular.
I'm interested in
history of reading
and oral storytelling
and written texts.
DEMBA BA: Hello.
My name is Demba Ba.
I'm in the School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences.
And I use mathematics,
statistical modeling,
and computing to understand
how large scale systems operate
when they work the way
they're supposed to
and when they don't work
the way they're supposed to.
So more recently, I've been
interested in applications
of math, statistical
modeling, and computing
to neuroscience
and understanding
how the brain works.
ELIZABETH KNOLL:
I'm Elizabeth Knoll.
I'm the Assistant Provost for
Faculty Appointments working
with Judy, and I'm delighted
to see that you're all really
here.
MINA CIKARA: Hello.
My name is Mina Cikara.
I'm in the Department
of Psychology,
and I study the
cognitive affective
and neural bases of inter-group
conflict and violence.
SCOTT KUINDERSMA: Hi,
I'm Scott Kuindersma.
I'm in the School of Engineering
and Applied Sciences.
I work in robotics at the
intersection between control,
optimization, and
machine learning.
ELIZABETH ANCARANA:
And as Judy mentioned,
I'm Elizabeth Ancarana, the
Assistant Provost for Faculty
Development and Diversity in
the office of the President
and the Provost.
And I join Judy and Alan
and my other colleagues
here in welcoming
you all to Harvard.
We're just so delighted
to see you here.
I have the pleasure of
introducing our panelists.
But before I do, I just
wanted to echo Judy's comments
about how we really are
here for you as a resource.
In addition to our colleagues
in the dean's offices,
in your departments, your
department chairs, et cetera,
over the years Judy and
I and our colleagues
have amassed a vast
network of people
that we can help to
introduce and connect you
to as you navigate
your experience right
now in the beginning
during your transition
to Harvard and the
Cambridge-Boston area,
but as you develop and progress
through your career at Harvard.
I was in the FAS doing faculty
recruitment for a decade
before moving into the provost's
office almost three years ago.
And a lot of faculty
come our way,
and it's just such a pleasure
to work with all of you.
So any time you have a question,
you don't know where to go,
you don't know who to
ask, give us a ring
and we'll make sure
you're doing just fine.